let's look at the another move which is
Knight to c3 against Knight to c3 we are
going to stick with our plan pretty much
similar so we are going to play in
Knight to d7 and again here there are
two moves has been played in one of my
game my opponent responded with Bishop
cross C 6 and after B cross C 6 he
played Bishop to f4 and here I capture
this Knight and again why it has few
options if white plays B cross E 4 then
after Queen to b4 attacking the bishop
as well as b2 white game will become
very very passive so that's why it's
unlike that you are going to face D
cross E Phi so most logical move looks
like Bishop cross E Phi attacking the
Queen but here black can play again the
similar concept which is Queen to g6
attacking the c2 and giving up the c7
which is anyway it's a double pawn so in
one of my game my upon responded with
the move castling on the King side and I
grab the opportunity to take this phone
and after Queen to f3 I played the move
e 6 and here my opponent captured the c7
and I played Bishop to e7 and now he
played in accurate move which is rook a
to C 1 this is what happened when the
opponent doesn't have any clue and he
just randomly go for attacking your
piece here I continue with very very
energetically so I first of all play
Bishop to g5 attacking the rook and my
opponent played rook c2 even instead of
rooks E - even if he would have played
Bishop to f4 then the very simple will
be castling on the Kings side this line
pretty much win the piece out right so
white has to play Knight to e2
afterwards we are going to play Bishop
d4 attacking
Queen and after Queen to g3 we are going
to capture this Bishop and no matter how
white we capture White will lose a piece
so for example if Knight cross f4 then
very simple will be rook takes and
please load Queen cannot capture the
rook because at the end it will be mated
so that's why this line is winning
outright for the black so that's why in
the game my opponent responded with Luke
c2 even but this is again one kind of
losing mistake because now we can play
Bishop to d3 attacking the rook which is
stuck on f1 and the only way to defend
this Luke is Knight to e2 but after very
simple rook to f6 attacking the Queen
and after Queen to g3 we have a very
simple move which is Bishop to d2 and
something is going to fall in the game
my opponent desperately try Queen to d6
but after King to f2 and the two rooks
are connected something will definitely
draw from the white camp so that is how
you should respond if you open in place
bishop cross c6 and Bishop to f4 instead
of Bishop cross c6 your opponent can
immediately try
Bishop to f4 at this point but now we
can simply capture this Knight and again
why it has two responses
if white capture with the D pawn then
black has this fantastic move which is
Queen to b4 attacking two spots so
Bishop on f4 as well as the g2
and here white has a two options so in
the first game my opponent try Bishop
cross d7
but after very simple Bishop cross d7
the threats remain same so my opponent
decided to play Bishop to d2 but after
very simple Queen to see foals
stopping the castling and b3 I simply
dropped my Queen to the C file and after
castle on the Kings side the planning of
the black is very simple black wants to
play the e 6 and then castle the Queen
side with no problem at all
so Bishop to d7 doesn't create anything
in another game my opponent tried Queen
to f3 so supporting this Bishop I played
first of all c6 attacking the bishop and
after a 3 which has a cunning idea that
if for example if I capture like this
then white can play a wonderful moon
which is Luke to a 2 and that Queen is a
goner so of course I didn't fall for
that
so I played Queen to c5 and after b4 I
simply drop my queen back to the b6 and
now White has to deal with this threat
of C captures Bishop so my opponent
plays Bishop to a4 but after very simple
a 6 castling on the King side and Bishop
to e7 my opponent plays rook to e1 but
after i Cashion's short it's time to
have a look who has the better position
and please note not only black has a
wonderful pawn structure on the Queen
side but black also has open F file and
fortunately the Queen is sitting there
so this is again a wonderful position
for black
so that was about D cross ePHI now most
likely your pond is going to play Bishop
cross ePHI against this I am
recommending that you should play Queen
to g6 our familiar transition and here
White has a few options let's look at
the first option which is the word
obvious what happens if white is going
to capture the lose d5 pawn so night
cross d5 so it has a threat of night
cross c7 but this can be buried with a
fantastic move which is Queen cross g2
so attacking the rook attacking the
knight so first obvious move is night
cross c7 but here we can play King to d8
and after night cross 8 they are going
to capture this rook and after King to
e2 Queen captures Queen rook captures
Queen and Knight captures ePHI D
captures E Phi and King to f8 you can
see white will lose a piece because that
night will not come out
so that is the trick exists in night to
defy line another two moves can be
placed bishop cross d7 well here we are
going to capture with the king and again
if night cross D Phi then Queen to be to
this time why it doesn't have even check
and instead of night cross FIFA if your
opponent plays Queen to f3 attacking the
pole and we can simply play a6 and after
castle and Bishop to d6
black has no problem at all and please
note that y DS also has a loose pawn on
C and the final third move white can try
is this very simple-looking castling on
the King side but after this we can
simply play the move c6 attacking the
bishop and after Bishop to a4 you can
play the move Knight cross e file and
after D cross e far we can play a six
and look at we have a wonderful pair of
bishop with a very very solid structure
so there is no need to go further the
simple idea is V Bishop can either goes
to the c500 e7 and then the next moment
black and castle on the King side which
a wonderful bishop pair with the open F
file for the attack
so that is all about Knight to c3 move
now the third move I want to consider is
Bishop cross c6 immediately and after
because c6 if you open place Bishop to
f4 then this line will be a
transposition which we are going to see
soon so the another bird of is looking
move is castling on the Kings side and
here I'm suggesting that you should play
Knight to d7 so pretty much all of this
line can be easily met with Knight to d7
and here there are three moves has been
tried the first move tried which is most
obvious one Bishop to f4 but again this
one we can met with Knight cross e file
and D cross e fire does not make any
sense because we can play Queen to b6
and that pawn has been misplaced also it
can be locked with the mu e 6 so the
most logical reply is Bishop cross Aoife
and now again of a familiar transition
which is Queen to b6 and here in one of
my game my opponent responded with
Bishop cross c7 and I responded with
Bishop cross c2 and Queen d2 has been
placed instead of Queen to d2 if the
opponent plays Queen to e2 then Bishop
d3 will lap the rook so your opponent
has to be careful over here and here I
responded with the movie 6 and after
Knight to c3 I challenge the Queen with
the move Queen to d3 mayapan I responded
with Queen to a5 and here I responded
with Bishop to e7 and now he played rook
to even so it looks threatening for a
moment but actually it's not because now
we can play Queen to a5 supporting the
pawn and if you open insists to attack
on e say e 6 with the move Queen to
III then first of all we can hit this
Bishop and after Bishop goes to the g3
we can simply play King to f7 and black
covered everything the father game goes
like this so my opponent plays rook to
c1 but after Bishop to g5 which is a
very very good move it forced the f4
move from the white which why doesn't
want to play and black and play Bishop
to f6 and the father games goes like
this my Ivan responded with the move
Queen to e2 attacking the bishop but
after a very simple Bishop to d3 my
threat is Bishop cross defy so my
opponent parry with Bishop to f2 after
that I played Bishop to b5 and because
he got annoyed by this Bishop my
opponent captured this Bishop and after
pawn recaptured we don't need to go
further
although the mercury is balanced Black
has attacking bishop and White has a
very passive bishop and finally I
managed to win this game so that was the
first move if your opponent plays Bishop
to f4
now instead of Bishop to f4 in another
game my opponent trial rook to e1 but
again I can I can capture this night and
please note if D captures then Queen g6
and black position is very very fine so
of course the most logical replies Luke
cross ePHI afterwards I played again
Queen to g6 and here my upon I responded
with Knight 283 protecting that pawn and
I played the movie six sometimes black
can also capture this Knight but in this
game I didn't so my opponent played up
to c3 I played Bishop to d6 attacking
the rook and after rook to e1
I simply Castle on the Kings side and
now it's white turn to show what is get
in the game I open responded with Bishop
to e3 but up to very simple Bishop to
ash tree the game finished very very
quickly so you can see this rook is
stopping Queen to come to the f3 and as
the g3 has been played it can be simply
made with the move Queen to e4 and now
how the white is going to defend this
so that is one way if the open places
look to even the final mood tried is the
nature looking move f4 but again we can
capture this night and again why it has
the only choice which is F cross e for
if you open place D cross E Phi then a
very simple is Queen check and after
king - h1 we can simply capture this
pawn and white will be a pawn down for
nothing so that's why F cross e Phi is
pretty much force but again we can play
Queen to g6 and is capturing the c2 and
the funny enough is in one of my game my
opponent played the MU c3 and that can
be made with losing a piece with Bishop
captures beavin so that's why c3 is
impossible so only logical moves Knight
- III afterwards we can play the movie 6
and after c3 now we can play Bishop to
e7 and look at that horrible night it
doesn't have any good space to go
further and next move black and castle
on the King side and black has a
wonderful position along with the bishop
there so that is pretty much you need to
know if the opponent plays Bishop cross
c6